from the wheel of death to juggling and
balancing acts wow the vegas spectacular
is up and running again at the rio
jillian lopez takes us behind the scenes
with some of the stars of the show
well all i can say is wow we're here at
the rio getting a behind-the-scenes look
of wow the vegas spectacular i have paul
and alex behind me juggling away there
you go
well i could sit here and watch you guys
do this all day but let's talk a little
bit congrats on the show coming back
paul for people who haven't been to the
show what can they expect when they come
in this beautiful theater well they're
going to be they're going to be wow to
see so many new acts and it's going to
be it's an amazing show there are great
people the great acts and and we're
having a lot of fun performing together
yeah this seems like a lot of fun and
i'm in the action here and alex let's
talk a little bit you have changed roles
over the years you've gone from juggler
to comedian
what is your favorite part of the show
or something that really stands out when
people come to see it well definitely is
they icarian actor that actually is the
actor you will gonna see in some minutes
and it's always been my favorite text in
general and many years ago i started to
talk with our director of the show try
to
say to him why we don't bring a you
carry neck he was already in his mind
and so at the end it happened
and we will enjoy it now yeah the acts
are bigger and better than ever and i've
seen the show once and i love the theme
of the water and the beautiful backdrops
behind us and what are the themes that
we get to see throughout the night if
you come to see wow well there's always
something a surprise with the scenes
that you see in the back there's always
a a scene of a pirate ship or or the
beautiful caribbean ocean or there's
always something that will happen that
will surprise the audience and i think
that's one of the parts that that people
enjoy watching i was gonna say there's
always a lot of surprises and if you're
in the audience you are part of the show
do you guys have fun just seeing
everyone come in and especially after
being on a hiatus how great does it feel
to see fans back in here coming to
support the show well it just give us
the feeling that we are back to life
because what we get from the human
contact
it's you cannot describe it so after
months and months awaiting this moment
just be on stage again and to see the
smile even if we are just guessing it
from the eyes because with the mask we
cannot see it but we feel the energy
with the plows and with the standing
ovation at the end it just brings us
back to life
absolutely we've waited too long to see
you guys back on stage so let's get to
it we have a really special performance
that we're getting a sneak peek of and i
hear it's uh something you don't want to
miss so let's take a look
so
jc me and you let's do it
wow the vegas spectacular runs nightly
at the rio at 7 pm with additional shows
at 9 30 pm on tuesday wednesday and
saturday they are dark on fridays